لكن السؤال الان هو الى اي مدى وصل برنامج
ايران النووي وهل باتت ايران على اعتاب
صنع القنبله النوويه
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه اعلنت في
تقرير سابق لها ان مخزون ايران المقدر من
اليورانيوم المخصب بلغ اكثر من ثلاثه
وعشرين ضعفا للحد المنصوص عليه في اتفاق
مدير الوكاله رافائي اعلن مطلع الشهر
الجاري ان الوكاله نجحت في تركيب اجهزه
لمراقبه التخصيب في منشاتي فوردو وناتنز
الايرانيتين الا ان دراس يعتبر الخطوه غير
كافيه لمراقبه انشطه الظهران النوويه وقال
ان مخزون ايران من اليورانيوم المخصبه
ارتفع باكثر من الربع في ثلاثه اشهر
واوضح ان ذلك يشمل مخزونها من اليورانيوم
المخصب بنسبه تصل الى 20% والذي يقترب من
نصف طن اما مخزونها من اليورانيوم العالي
التخصيب فيصل الى نسبه 60% والذي يزيد على
مئه كيلوغرام
ويقول الخبراء ان 50 كيلو جراما تكفي
بالفعل لصناعه سلاح نووي في حال كان
اليورانيوم مخصبا اكثر بقليل
الاتفاق النووي الايراني ابرم في الرابع
عشر من يوليو 2015 في فيينا توصلت ايران
وامريكا وبريطانيا وفرنسا وروسيا والصين
والمانيا الاتفاق عرف بالسم خطه العمل
الشامل المشتركه بموجبه باتت تخضع انشطه
ايران النوويه لبرنامج الرقابه وتفتيش
تابع للوكاله الذريه
الثامن من مايو 2018 اعلان الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب انسحاب
بلاده احاديا من الاتفاق وفرض عقوبات على
ايران مطالب ايران للعوده الى الاتفاق
النووي ضمانات امريكيه بعدم انسحاب اي
رئيس مستقبلا من الصفقه تخلي الوكاله
الذريه عن تحقيق مدته ثلاث سنوات في
اليورانيوم المخصب في منشات ايرانيه
مختلفه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات